elecciones clave para el oficialismo el
estado de barinas cuna del ex presidente
hugo chávez decidirá por segunda ocasión
quién llevará las riendas de este
territorio cargado con un alto
simbolismo para el gobierno los
candidatos no se den un ápice por un
lado jorge arriaza el elegido por
miraflores para disputar la gobernación
promete una mayor conexión con los
marinenses porque vamos a ver vamos a
gobernar juntos cuenta no me pueden
dejar solo programa vamos a dejar más
nunca no nos vamos a conectar más nunca
la oposición se decantó por sergio
garrido quien batalla contra una fuerte
maquinaria electoral patrocinada por el
gobierno central
a pesar del panorama económico que rodea
venezuela las dificultades han
disminuido considerablemente durante el
proceso electoral las calles han
cambiado a una mejor apariencia y las
colas por la gasolina se redujeron
considerablemente
ahorita también negra gasolina porque al
gobierno le interesa pero espere que
pase unos días o pierde no que esté yo
volvemos a la misma situación peor va a
ser por primera vez desde el año 1998 un
familiar directo del fallecido
presidente chávez no ocupará el puesto
de gobernador los resultados de las
elecciones del pasado noviembre en las
que la oposición se llevó el triunfo
fueron desestimadas por el tribunal
supremo de venezuela programando un
nuevo proceso electoral que marcará
según expertos la fuerza del chavismo en
la tierra de su fundador